she's coming  [Music]  oh boy it's what's the largest struggle  that ever existed thought to have been  extinct for two million years that  thing's out there  it define didn't kill it but you just  put a tracker on it you guys ever  watched Shark Week  the mega D pg-13 experience as an IMAX  August 10  we have the discovery of a lifetime  we've all believed the Mariana Trench  was the deepest place on earth but we  encountered the completely new world and  comprehend it  we should find all sorts of species  completely unknown to science there is  something down here oh my god smegal  have done he's kidding right  mendler dolls were thought to have been  extinct they're not getting eaten by  some prehistoric fish you sure about  this not really  if you want me to go instead oh well  look god this man okay good stars lying  you